la frágil sensación de normalidad en
múltiples ciudades ucranianas lejos de
los frentes de batalla terminó
repentinamente las condenas a los
últimos ataques contra la
infraestructura civil se han sucedido en
la Esfera europea una vez más Rusia ha
mostrado al mundo lo que representa es
el terror y la brutalidad la Unión
Europea dice que el ataque
indiscriminado a civiles equivale a un
crimen de guerra y algunos estados
miembros como Estonia y lituania
reiteran que no es el momento de dar
marcha atrás ante Rusia
cada vez que alguien piensa tenemos que
ayudar a Putin para salvarle la cara y
darle algo para que no haga una
estupidez eso solo le anima a seguir
avanzando porque se toma Este
apaciguamiento como un signo de
debilidad
lo que tenemos que hacer es proporcionar
defensa aérea desde al lado Aliado para
que los ucranianos puedan proteger sus
ciudades porque Rusia está
definitivamente escalando para dañar a
los civiles
el presidente francés Emmanuel macon
reafirmó el apoyo militar al gobierno
ucraniano y expresó su preocupación
los ataques deliberados de Rusia en todo
el territorio ucraniano y contra la
población civil es un cambio profundo en
la naturaleza de esta guerra el
presidente de Ucrania también mantuvo
conversaciones con el canciller alemán y
pidió una respuesta unida y dura se ha
programado una reunión virtual de
emergencia del g7 para el martes en la
que intervendrá bolodimirselenski